you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game hmm
okay let's try be six as a start
and go from there
maybe we turn it into a French on e 4 D
5 c4 hmm okay how about C 5
let's see what white does
you
potential benoni structure Knight c3
seems pretty flexible not committing the
pond'rous yet but maybe I win a tempo
against the Queen so this is something
white has to weigh I have a development
with tempo at some stage maybe the night
had come out to defend d4 not the first
time I'm playing this guy but I imagine
this is the first time standard game
yeah
bullet okay let's take
on Queen takes I'm able to develop with
tempo and then get in d5 already so a
benoni
okay probably start with d6
although there is some kind of a what
they call a snake Benoni a favorite of
chess players right any opening that has
a name to it or any opening that has a
name to it any opening that has an
animal's name reptile okay let's start
with d6 who cares about the snake
let's just go with d6 maybe I fee and
keto Knight f6 probably before I decide
where to put my bishop
I don't know how great a future he has
on e7 I'll probably go with being cut
out so let's see how aggressive white
approaches this there's a pretty
aggressive approach in that of efore or
even a modest setup with Bishop f4 and
III something I've played before
in both blitz and standard so we have
only moved upon so far
this night the king night will sometimes
like to travel into the sea for square
to apply pressure on d6 this is this is
a weak point in my position not them not
upon that is that you can access so
easily
but yeah something that the minor pieces
can converge on the bishop and the King
Knight
to see form so let's go with g6
I want to get I want to get my rook on
EA Taz soon as possible
ah a check okay it doesn't seem like too
much of an inconvenience I guess the
idea here is what exactly I think I'm
going to block with the fish shop hmm
they're not going to trade yeah I don't
think that they're gonna trade here by
block I'm going to block but I'm just
wondering should it be the night or the
bishop
and tells me it should be the Bishop III
I think I want to do something like
night a five-hour night a 6 into c7 this
is a push that I would like to get in at
some point
also maybe I want to keep open the
option of a pin
let's try Bishop d7 I really don't know
if it's the right moment but those are
at least the reasons I'm assigning for
Bishop instead of night on a four I
don't want to take because I'm just
helping the rook you know there's even
some possibilities for a pawn sacrifice
with a little bit more development in
and by that I mean once I'm castled
ideas like just pushing the beep on and
if they take well maybe it in the end
it's not even a sack because I could be
capturing on e4 so that right there is a
bit surprising you know definitely a bit
surprising probably now just the night
it's not bad to capture but yeah I was
just expecting white to avoid the
exchange of light square bishop
sometimes this is a piece you look to
exchange for a night just because of the
you know working with a lack of space
here on the black end so probably just
the night yeah let me just double-check
here cuz there's gonna be some pressure
against this guy soon so if I take with
the night yeah that should still be
right take with the night Bishop f4
I can't develop my bishop just yeah I
think that this is still the right way
expecting Bishop f4 and I think I have
to invest them of a six to stop Knight
here you know you should really be
racing in for a knight on c4 what would
I like to have happen here I'd like one
more exchange I'd like to have that hmm
it's a little bit interesting because
typically you don't want to exchange
like if I'm going with the kingside
fiend cut out my fiend cut out Bishop is
quite a valuable piece however you know
it may reinforce my control over these
dark squares in the center now that's a
very very committal move one of the
thoughts I have here is that I'm not
gonna have to worry so much about my d6
pawn anymore and also I wonder where
he's gonna go where will his home be
Knight g4 comes to mind this is a very
committal move F for this is a dog and I
could be looking to get on there going
to Castle kingside excuse me I don't
think I should be going with anything
other than Bishop here yeah some quick
strike against d6 at the moment it's
unprotected but there's no no quick
strikes against d6 looking at castles
rook to e8 maybe I could win that pond
we'll see this may seem natural but
there's a couple issues with it Knight
g4 and also it's on an unprotected
square Queeny seven castles are not
threatening to take because I end up in
a pin
so probably just castle yeah a night on
g4 a queen on v6 very very strong so
expecting
here
if I go a six probably a four
if I go rectory a
probably rook to e1 hmm well I think
it's okay to still start with a six
let's do that they could push a five but
I believe I'm the I'm in a better
position development wise for the
opening up for the physician if the
position is going to open up I think I'm
better off so what about rook b8 in b5
another idea I mean they've they've
weakened b3 and b4 I don't have a way to
get to B form but I could maybe think
about these two squares these are holes
one pond move away from controlling both
this also opens up a Queen b6 move so I
think this was a good idea a six a four
this is more weakening of the two pawn
moves there is some type of clamping
down idea like could maybe go in four
but this Knight has a very important
responsibility I will be looking at some
point to make a a strong knight move to
unmask this guy
if it has intent to do this I know it
puts pressure on the pond but at the
same time you know if white is ever
going for a five
seven to be too sensitive
no just kind of looking at something
else other than a rook move for right
now if I play c4 the squares that I give
up
d4 and b4 b4 our excuse me d4 is really
the one that concerns me more so the
knight could post up there
but I think this is uh this is fine I
think I want to go see for
yeah you know what if I once I please
see four then I'm even prepared to play
b5 because I have a queen check on b6
I'm going back to this rook t8 move for
starters
uh yeah maybe it is better to first put
pressure on e4 because if I do see four
right now
c4 Bishop e3 Knight g4 Bishop here
rook e8
rookie 1c for Bishop III blocks the
rooks view of e4 and I could take on e4
I think I may be going a bit too you
know my talk of f7 being sensitive I
think that's uh yeah too far-fetched I
should be looking for some more direct
stuff so let's just throw an immediate
punch at4
I think the rook moved to e1 is best
there is of course Queen here
oh you know what here's another thing to
look out if the rook is on e 1 my idea
of c4 Knight c5 Knight d3 is really
packing a strong punch
yeah so this is another reason why I'm I
think at least I'm liking rook to e8 the
rook is on this square my my knight one
day might gain a valuable tempo Queen d3
is interfering with c4 by hmm can I not
just force that through
now c4 is in it's hitting with tempo
Queen here I have Knight b6 I mean I may
have to go here to get this move in and
then revisit this square okay so this
was a waste yeah this this queen is
misplaced now
also when my knight gets to see 5e for
is really hit let's do it Queen b6
Knight c5 Knight b3 93 94 to check first
or not hmm
well let's consider something here this
pawn is attacked twice it's defended
twice tonight c5 hits it a third time
then be5
hmm tactical position right around the
corner I mean it's already quite dynamic
hmm Queen b6 check rook or a king in the
corner Knight c5 Bishop e3 I think I
want to do this straightaway yeah let's
get the
and straightaway
expecting e5
yep it's getting pretty crazy but my
night on d3 Wow
that's gonna be a beast is it not night
on d3 night G night b3 night d3 good
pieces I have all my pieces playing
except for my queen there defending e4 I
could play Knight d3 right now
it's b5 a move b5 pawn takes pawn takes
Knight takes Queen b6 Knight d4 Knight
d3
no no I could
this right now because I have three
attackers so b5 FICO b5 takes takes
Knight takes I take on e4 that's a
desirable exchange they get my a queen
site pawn I got their center ponds so b5
this is the move I have to look at
because this will spring both of these
rooks to life so if I go b5 I could go
Knight d3 right now but B v e5 takes
pawn takes Knight takes I'm missing
anything
there King is still the more vulnerable
there on this open dog and all if things
are opening up I think I want to go with
b5 right now before I do this I still
want to squeeze a little bit more out of
the fact that my knight is exerting
pressure on e4 is this necessary though
b5 can I just go straight in for a night
here I can win this pawn potentially
Knight d3 Queen b6 into B 2 they may be
able to get that beep on back ok b5
let's let's make a move this isn't a
position to I've already spent enough
time probably too much
such a sharp position so let's see now
this night's the stability of this night
is in question before and I'm
undermining the eform I have majority
three versus two on the Queen side so
could one day end up with a passed on
sharp position only what known yeah one
pawn exchanged in the light square
bishop sand that's it so let's see I
think I have my pieces in a good
position
yeah their Bishop really isn't playing
my rook is opposite their queen I should
keep this in mind I'm threatening to
basically win the game with the b4
Knight takes pawn that's just uh this is
the heart I can't can't just drop that
hon so I'm expecting e5 here or takes
first and then e5 just kind of rolling
the dice on sharpening things up because
otherwise you're just dropping you for
you
'if five takes now my queen is on this
twice and I could win there d5 pawn and
soon this is gonna hit really really
hard hit the rook also kind of stopped
the Queen's influence along this
diagonal I don't know how important a
diagonal that is but he's really doing a
fantastic job this one of these interior
squares when the Queen's here giving
check Knight f2 ensuing check you know
check King h19 f2 ideas
so let's see
you
he five or takes one of these two
you know this screen v6 move I speak of
okay let's do this first green v6 can be
met with Bishop III so I may want to
actually play Knight g4 before I play
Queen b6
let's see 2 to 1 now queenside Knight
takes pawn I believe I'll be taking with
this guy
c5 it is
all right let's take
3:42 how to recapture they can take with
the rook but I'm fine with seeing that
they take with the rook the rook would
be defending this pawn but yeah I could
just take the rook and then take care
where might I be vulnerable as these
pieces are moving about where might I
have unprotected pieces these are the
things that you know I'm looking for in
such an open position one unprotected
piece you are tactically vulnerable and
then if there's two that's just two too
many
so let's see
Knight takes pawn Knight takes pawn this
is a sensitive point the night is on e5
one attacker one defender on pawn takes
my Knights attacked I don't have much of
a choice takes their
hmm interesting
okay isn't this pretty killer move clean
v6 just going to do it that's what have
them work it out threatening the night
threatening discovered checks they
really take here I could do this
Wow okay there really isn't a good
discovered check here hmm okay I don't
buy that night here first hmm
okay 250 let's work this one out here
the the discovered check there's going
to be Bishop III however I could take
the rook and beyond the Queen yeah I
almost overlooked that and I could track
this guy down I don't want them to end
up with two past pawns in the center or
two connected pounds in the center I
think I could do this Bishop III I'm
taking the rook
on the Queen
and I'm going to move my queen out of
the way encounter tech d5 okay so right
here because on this I want to be able
to take here
you know there should have been
something there so on their queen by
taking that rook
and the Queen's unprotected where are
they unprotected
maybe the rook one day the night may
have a responsibility
okay now the bishops unprotected let's
gain this tempo and now if he's kicked
off of this diagonal Queen she might
revisit this b6 square or a seven so
this is right where they were weakened
with their last moves so I'm striking at
it right away my first thought was to
take here but this is a very valuable
move opens up my bishop kicks the bishop
off of the diagonal and now probably
Queen b6 Queen b6 right now I'm gonna go
here yeah let's give that check King
gets to go to f1 now it's tempted to go
to a7 but why not exert some pressure on
one of the white pieces okay now what if
i push the knight around and then Knight
takes h2 that might be a killer idea I
think it is well then he doesn't have to
move I could just take on push Knight
takes so probably just capture them
complaining night in here right away
let's open let's make sure the Bishop's
opened up could take him out he's not a
reliable piece anymore my nights really
strong I don't want I feel like I don't
want to jump into e3 right away but
right around this point I'll be seeking
some clarity 2 3 4 I'm not the exchange
hmm okay can I do something thing
see Bishop e5 I think I could do Bishop
e5 I want to lure that Bishop away from
e3 let's go for this Bishop takes Bishop
Knight e3 Knight takes bishop I may have
no I don't have that move but I could
play rook takes and then if this I have
that knight on a light square many
pieces on light squares many forks right
around the corner
he's unprotected this is so this is
giving some pretty serious direction my
last move okay now my idea was rook
takes their Bishop is unprotected I
could drop in here this is a big
intersection square III this pawn has
passed but I should I should be hitting
very very fast threat here I think is
rook f5 and this pump could maybe even
get here and I could ignore it
looking at Queen f2 mates
so let's see I've weakened my King
without my dark square bishop around
these are weak squares 94-94 let's also
keep in mind that this could be made if
the Queen goes too far away so she's
restricted the bishops restricted
they're pushing the pawn so probably
this
night right here oh man no no no no not
here I could take the bishop Knight
takes and then this I'm threatening this
right now but if this movie is played I
want to take the bishop to lure the
night away from hitting my queen
what didn't see that move that's not
working though I'm threatening made on
f2 I guess that was a try but certainly
shocked me a little bit threatening made
on f2 also just night here next
guess I'm on b2 as well
you know Richter detail okay
what sound let's throw in this check now
43 seconds let's say King King there has
an interesting idea must be said okay
let's let's try this if night here I
what can I do
oh let's see have to watch out for Forks
now it's scary how about we go here
threatening something against their King
multiple checks there is this check here
my night is not stable and on this
square anymore but at least I'm throwing
a punch here so maybe there's no time
for a ch3 both of us are under a minute
like I just want to get my king to a
better square okay let's give this
cheque ooh
wow that was bad and it was really bad
see what I did on that diagonal don't
repeat that
give this check
hmm another check
Kyle their knight is pinned my knight is
stopping this pond four seconds is not a
lot how they missed that that's what
check I could just win that okay and got
this now just get the King to a light
square Wow sharp sharp game let's just
take that and where's the mate on the
rook yes we're just gonna play this one
out to mate on each two who really
really sharp a ton of stuff most likely
missed there yeah I could probably do
better than saying most likely yeah
definitely some stuff was missed there
Wow sharp stuff okay let's go into the
analysis Benoni
okay let's see yeah a bit questionable
a4 is a move here I was pointing out
that I wouldn't want to take if a4 is
played it helps out the rook but they
just went in for a capture which isn't
so popular well really the Bishop b5
move right here so what is this move 7
there should be 5 move not so popular
right so something better is f4 or
Knight f3 as mentioned going for this
plan but that never really happened they
just went for Bishop b5 here and this is
this is a welcome sight to have at least
one minor piece off
I mean sometimes you'll see white takes
steps like h3 before night here just to
prevent the bishop for a night exchange
I'm lacking some space so I'd like to
see one minor piece at least exchanged
and yeah I think that this is I think
that this is good for black I think this
is already a position that's mmm
you know I've beyond I think it's gone
beyond equalizing and better in this
position exerting pressure on e4 you
know well the reading is now up so you
know we are right around this point here
so the typical advantage for white
having some space but as soon as that
capture came about right Bishop takes d7
let's go back right here 0.74 after I
played g6 but as soon as Bishop e5 is
played it goes down and then as soon as
the capture comes about it goes down
further and then it's after f4 it likes
black so something other than f4 I mean
if white is going to go in for this
which really isn't the right idea to
exchange off light square bishop like
that if they are going to go in for that
f4 isn't really the way to go it's just
tough to get this guy working you know
the idea was to play e5 but I'm better
equipped to handle the opening up of the
position better developed and again as
we're seeing the king is very vulnerable
that f-pawn has moved open on this
diagonal so one more okay I didn't well
I missed something
Queen b7 I guess was the last big moment
that was another shift and he's six a4
pretty standard let's just put on that
analysis here Queen d3 yeah Queen d3 was
asking for some trouble because I'm
getting this bush in very valuable tempo
in such a dynamic position like this
just you know having that one tempo that
could really really turn things c4 you
know wants to jump right in but b5 is
fine as well takes Queen b6 Knight check
Bishop there and I'm able to get this
continuation B up the exchange doesn't
like Queen b7
Queen a5 oh huh why was I so focused on
striking at the pond along a diagonal
what's wrong with Queen v7 do I end up
in a pin that's uncomfortable no with
this evaluation it's saying I have to do
something like this yeah that's
something that I should be avoiding but
okay I didn't see this ensuing pin
against my queen I should have just
moved forward yeah
what's another reason why this would be
better than b7 just I could look at it
as I'm observing more of the white
pieces all right all she doing is
staring at a couple pawns but what about
striking at this guy in having a couple
pieces in mind yeah
maybe coming down here for a check one
day as well okay yeah
Queen to a5 they didn't take advantage
of this
they just defended that guy and now
Knight g4 queen a7 or B 6 and now e4 is
good oh I could play this because of
made on f2 I was saying what kept me
away from playing e4 was oh they have
two attackers on it but no not really
that Queen is I was saying it later on
in the game that the queen is restricted
well she's currently restricted right
now very important she stays here so I
should have got gone in for e4 here
taking is fine but yeah this is this is
more direct because if the knight moves
I don't even know where he moves I have
take on h2 and I can revisit looking at
these squares
okay that move getting fancy is a local
stock fish here
Queen III Bishop takes Queen when a
piece yes there's multiple ways to do it
it was a really nice try what they did
in the game I must say like it sent me
some problems I mean objectively I'm
sure it's always winning here and I have
mate right away oh my goodness Queen
takes wreck I have made an f2 oh good
grief oh I missed me one wasn't I saying
right around here like well there yeah
now now I saw only after I captured here
that I realized oh I'm threatening
making one no you had me one okay
Oh messy messy messy messy
nothing nothing slipped away though I
wasn't a fan of my technique now
especially especially when I'm trying to
like this
Queen a6 to g1
okay yeah it wasn't losing but yeah I
could have I could have gone for a
million won or taking a ruck okay we're
in Bullitt mode at that point but I
guess the yeah I didn't miss anything
right okay
playing out to me yeah the big thing
here is straight out of the opening the
decision really to exchange that minor
piece you know just just playing out
let's say a popular line Knight f3 just
to give you a feel Bishop g7 there
should be two castles castles rookie 892
going for this
eighty-four 95 not sure how much further
I'm gonna play it out and now g5 or
night age five that's pretty sharp huh
hmm
9h five maybe I mean there's this but we
have the bishop pair really shattered
kingside structure but it's a this is
the kind of stuff you get with the
Benoni I mean a really sharp game wild
ideas like g5 9 h5 yeah really committal
move but it's securing the knight on e5
interesting but yeah I just want to give
you a little bit of a feel for you know
the next handful of moves which would be
to night looking at the c-4 square and
some interesting ideas here for black as
we're seeing if we go with something
that's a little bit more tame like Queen
c7 v 3 g5 again there are very many
games here but yeah interesting stuff
with g5 Knight h5 possibly but the big
thing here is to keep still for minor
pieces on board why usually does well to
keep all minor pieces aboard
ok well interesting game sharp 1 many
things miss Mayton one missed as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and
as always I hope you got something out
of it that's all for now take care bye